the democrats proving once again how
totally inept and clueless they are on
the issues kamala harris was asked point
blank about soaring inflation the veep
offering up this mess of an answer
but now
inflation is is really high are you
concerned about a recession the
administration said
um that they weren't that worried about
the about inflation and then
that changed i think that
there can be no higher priority
then what we have been clear is our
highest priority which is bringing down
the costs
and the prices as much as we possibly
can and we will stay focused on that
that comes as a new report indicates joe
biden is getting irritated by democrats
who will not openly back him to run for
reelection
okay shall i start with the word salad
what do you think
i
i am really appalled by
her inability to put together a
thoughtful message even when given a
softball question
uh and i really i try to be a fan of
hers i recognize her historic uh her
historic importance but i have to say
this
the issue is whether or not
republicans can keep people interested
in their their incompetence the
democrats incompetence on immigration on
the economy on inflation on the border
and so forth
or will the democrats win out in the end
despite all this mixed messaging and
mis-messaging
by allowing the voters to focus instead
on the abortion ruling and uh you know
on january 6th the hearings today
appalling uh in terms of what they
reveal so it's a it's really a it's who
gets the message
pinata
and she's not helping them no i you
can't
the word salad is non-stop and there's
people who are actually suffering and
they want to know what's going to happen
and that does not inspire confidence i
hear somebody talking like that i don't
have confidence that i can you know
order them an uber home and they're not
going to throw up in it and i'm going to
you know have my rating be
completely decimated that doesn't make
any sense people are really struggling
and they've been told and gaslit for a
while oh it's going to get better it's
getting better it's not going to get
better it's getting worse
people
aren't going to forget about it because
they're facing it every single day you
know dana
when she was asked what biden had done
to lower the price of gas besides the
gas tax holiday
she didn't have an answer it is amazing
to me that you don't like you don't have
a ready answer it was like a couple
weeks ago the new press secretary she
was asked about the baby formula crisis
and she looked through her book she's
like i don't have everything on that
yeah they go you just have to you just
like those are the things you have to
have in your back pocket and i
do believe that inflation is their
biggest problem it is not their highest
priority i mean that's obvious and the
democrats themselves are saying that you
had an anonymous democrat quoted in a
cnn piece this week saying
they vacillate between not having to
play them or trying to blame somebody
else but they're the democrats are
waiting like which way are we going here
boss i think geraldo is right that
the democrats are hoping to hide their
economic failures by focusing on
something like roe v wade and
republicans are saying well there's roe
v wade but
they need to figure out a way to deal
with that communication as well but
they're planning to run just all across
the board on inflation today do you mind
if i call for this sound bite i just
think that this was significant sure
okay so abigail spamberger is a democrat
from virginia in a swing district she
is a democrat she's been saying that the
squad is wrong for a long time i asked
her if she would be willing to campaign
with biden that's what she said
i intend to do the campaigning myself i
am the candidate it's my name on the
ballot uh certainly when i first ran i
ran in an r plus seven district
and i won in that seat by getting out
speaking to voters making sure that they
know who i am and what it is that i
intended to do for them and you'll see a
lot more of that remember when stacey
abrams had a scheduling conflict and she
couldn't be with byron kamala harris
there's going to be a lot of that all
right jessie so if 75 percent of
americans say that the economy is bad
you can have x number of people worried
about roe versus wade uh i wonder if roe
versus wade will be as heavy on their
minds as the economy as it continues to
get worse getting closer to november i
think the economy trumps row uh what if
you have a door the far left will be
fired up about roe but
i just think it's overwhelming that the
people of this country are suffering
economically and that's not gonna that's
a taste that's not gonna leave their
mouths i am just relieved judge that
harris is going to tackle costs as well
as prices
not just the costs we're going to go
after the prices too
is she so bad you can smell the
politician through the screen she's only
good at memorization right and
i used to be well you can see kind of
how she's reciting things as she i used
to do this i i was hired
22 years old to to work in an asset
management company after college i
didn't know anything about economics but
i could memorize things and i could
speak and so we'd get up at these pitch
meetings where i would pretend to be the
salesman and what has changed and i'd
get up there and i'd just
recite beautifully what our sales pitch
was and the guy running it would go
all right waters what is a
mortgage-backed security
and i'd say
it's a security backed by a mortgage
and you go all right water sit down i
had no idea what i was talking about
it's the same thing with her hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now